this is a view of the cathedral where we
see the building a bit in its urban
context and most of em ER was rebuilt
after the two world wars the
destructions of world war one and two
but here on the north side of the
building as a cluster of older houses
with their sawtooth roof lines
characteristic of a medieval city some
of them rebuilt by all means but in
houses like this would have lived the
urban population wealthy from textile
production because this land down to the
north of the cathedral is by the river
song which was canalized to drive
textile mills whereas behind these
little medieval houses is a large post
Renaissance building which is in fact
the Bishop's Palace so the bishop's
palace is located to the north of the
choir whereas on the other side of the
building invisible to us from here are
the cannons houses